[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره وبمتابعه
الحياه لقمه العشرين انطلقت في بالي
الاندونيسيه اعملوا قمه مجموعه العشرين
بمشاركه ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الذي تراس ولد المملكه في القمه
الرئيس الاندلسيه جوكو دودو قال لدى
افتتاحه لقمه قاده مجموعه ال 20 انه لا
يجب الفشل مؤكدا على ضروره تجنب حرب
عالميه اخرى
الدنيا
على تحقيق النجاح ام اننا سوف نكون في
مواجهه فشل اخر اضافه الى مجموعه اعمالنا
الفاشله السابقه بنظري هذه القمه يجب ان
لا تفشل اندونيسيا عملت ما بوسعها لسد هذه
الهه الواسعه لكن النجاح لا يمكن ان يتحقق
الا اذا عملنا جميعا وبالتزام على تضيق هو
في خلافاتنا ونقدم شيئا ملموسا يعود من
نفع على العالم بصفاتنا نحمل رئاسه قمه
مجموعه العشرين فان الحوار هو الكفيل بسد
الفجوه في خلافاتنا وهذا لن يكون خيارا
فان التعاون سوف يكون مطلوبا وتقع على
كاهيلنا مسؤوليات تجاه العالم اجمع
المسؤوليه تعني انه يجب علينا ان نسجل
الستار على الحرب واذا لم تنتهي فسيصعب
علينا ان نمضي قدما وان نحقق الاستقرار من
اجل بل الاجيال القادمه يجب علينا الا
ندخل العالم في دهاليز الصراع او في حرب
بارده جديده
ان العالم يواجه تحديات غير عاديه يواجه
ازمه تلو الاخرى فجائحه كوفيت 19 لن تنتهي
بعد وهناك ازمه الامن الغذائي والامن
المالي وامن الطاقه التي اخذت العالم على
حين غاره ولا سيما في البلدان الناميه
كذلك موضوع الاسمده يجب ان لا يؤخذ بكل
سهوله وان لم نتخذ اجراءات مباشره لضمان
امدادات الاسمده بصوره كافيه وباسعار ضمن
المتناول فان العام القادم سيكون عاما اشد
صعوبه والازمه التي نعيشها اليوم قد تصبح
اشد وطاتا وازمه الغد قد تكون متجليه في
المواد الغذائيه الامر الذي سوف يؤثر على
المحاصيل في كافه انحاء العالم ولا سيام
بالنسبه للدول الناميه التي ستواجه صعوبات
وتحديات كبيره
قادت اكبر 20 اقتصادا في العالم يبحثون في
قمه بالي ملفات صعبه بينها ركود الاقتصادي
وحرب اوكرانيا التي خلفت ازمتي طاقه وغذاء
غيراء مسبوقتين
[موسيقى]
وفي متابعه الحيه ومباشره من موقع الحدث
من العاصمه الاندونيسيه بالي مع مفاجاه
العربيه الزملاء محمد الطميحي وزميله
فاطمه الزهراء قمه ببعديها الاقتصادي
والسياسيه من مدينه بالي نحن معكم
للمتابعه
لذلك رشا نحن متواجدين الان انا وزميله
فاطمه لتغطيه هذه القمه دائما جميله فاطمه
تقول بان هذه القمه هي قمه اقتصاديه
بامتياز ولكن دائما اختلف معها وقملها
شعورها سياسيه والتي تابعناها من
التصريحات الاخيره التي مثلا صدرت الكلمه
الافتتاحيه للرئيس الاندونيسي جوكو دودو
هو الذي تحدث فيها واعرض عن نقاوه ليس فقط
اندونيسيا وانما في العالم فيما يتعلق
بحرب عالميه الجديده تهديدات جديده في ما
يتعلق من الغذائي وايضا الدخول في حرب
بارد ما بين المعسرين الشرقي والغربي بعد
الخلاف والانقسام الحاصل ما بين الشرق
والغرب
بالنسبه للملفات السياسيه تضغط بشكل كبير
على هذه القمه ويبدا بان الزبير فاطمه
اهلا بك رشا واهلا بمشاهدين الكرام في هذه
التغطيه المستمره منذ الصباح المبكر اليوم
نحن الان نتحدث عن توقيت الساعه الثانيه
عشر بتوقيت بالي
قصه السياسه والاقتصاد
لما المصالح الاقتصاديه تختلف
والمصالح الاقتصاديه
تتشابك السياسه تختلف وبالتالي كل تحرك
سياسي محمد على الارض هو مدفوع بهدف
اقتصادي بحث لانه كل دوله تحاول ان تحافظ
على مصالح الاقتصاديه وبالتالي اظن انه
الجواب ما فينا صح ولا غلط اثنينهم لازم
يدعموا بعض لترتيب الاهداف والاستراتيجيات
او اي دوله والحفاظ على مصالحها السياسيه
والعسكريه الاقتصاديه همم رشا ثلاث نقط
الرئيسيه هو الحديث الساخن في كواليس
اجتماعات قمه العشرين واحد
العلاقات ما بين الصين والولايات المتحده
اضخم قوتين عسكريتين سياسييتين اقتصادتين
اعطتنا مفاجاه
عشيه انطلاق هذه القمه ان هناك اهتمام
للجلوس
ولا ربما ايجاد حلول للخلافات التي استمرت
لسنوات ما بين اهم لاعبين في الاقتصاد
العالمي 2 لربما موضوع اقل اهميه وهو ابن
مصر محمد همم كان في اجتماعات للبيت وانت
هذه همم تجمع رجالات الاعمال والقطاع
الخاص تحت مجموعه العشرين وكان انا الماسك
موجود ببعض بجلسه حواريه يوم امس
كما هو العاده كلامه دائما
يستحوذ على العناوين الكبيره للجرائد
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه خصوصا بعد استحواله
على تويتر
وتحدثه عن الفيس بيتش او حريه التع ومن
بعدها تهديد اي احد همم يتحدث او ينتقد
مقام به لكي يغلق حسابها هذا موضوع اخر او
بالطبع موضوع الروسي الاوكراني زلنسكي قبل
قليل كالوكلمه خلال الاجتماع او خلال
القمه اللي هي مغلقه بدات قبل حوالي
ساعتين تقريبا موضوع اوكرانيا وروسيا محمد
سياسي بحث يستحوذ على اهتمام القاده هنا
همم
بالمواجه العسكريه معه الروسيه والضغط على
روسيا من اجل الانسحاب من الاراضي كان
يتحدث عن محطه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه كان يتحدث ايضا على تبادل الاسرار
مع روسيه يحضر بدعم كبير جدا في هذه القمه
همم من ضمن الاسباب التي قادت الى هذا
الزمن وهذا الدعم هو غياب الرئيس الروسي
الذي اكتفى بارسال وزير خارجته سارجيله
ظروف للمشاركه بالنيابه عن في هذه القمه
نلاحظ ايضا ان الموضوع الروسي الاوكراني
كان حاضرا بقوه في الاجتماع والقمه التي
جمعت الرئيس الصيني والرئيس الفرنسي
المنوي المكرون هذه المره حيث طالب
المكرون ااه الرئيس شيبنج بالضغط على
موسكو من اجل حل الازمه في اوكرانيه سلبيا
والعوده مره اخرى الى المفاوضات فبالتالي
بالنسبه لمره اخرى شقه سياسي يحضن اهتمام
كبير ويبدو حتى الان انه الحديث عن
الملفات الاقتصاديه ملفات الامن الغذائي
ملفات امن الطاقه سلاسل الامداد يبدو
بانها مثلا متفق عليها ولكن لم تظهر على
السطح بنفس اهميه الخلاف السياسي الذي
ظهر جليا في قمه العشرين اليوم همم
يذكر عنوان اجتماعات قمه العشرين ببالي
لنتعافى معا لنتعافى بشكل قوي هذه كلمه
رايتها تتكرر كثيرا في خصوصا في كلمه
الرئيس الاندونيسي الذي ذكر كلمه سلم
كثيرا في كلمته الافتتاحيه يريد السلم لكي
نركز على الثلاث نقاط رئيسيه الامن
الغذائي والوضع من حيث التغير المناخ
وتاثيره على المحاصيل تاثيره على همم
الامدادات الغذائيه الامن الطاقه خصوصا
انه بنتحدث عن عن اهتمام كل الدول سواء
المستهلكه للطاقه والمنتجه للطاقه للتحول
بشكل سلس الى طاقه خضراء او طاقه همم
صديقه للبيئه خصوصا مع موضوع صفر همم
كربون او همم
سي او تو بشكل رئيسي وذلك لتخفيض درجه
حراره كوكب الارض اذا ونحن ايضا نتحدث عن
اهتمام بالرقمنا وغيرها من المواضيع التي
سوف لربما تصدر من خلال بيان الختامي لهذه
القمه في بالي نعم
ربما اذا كنت تسمعيني انت ومحمد
نعم الاندونيس
هي باعتبار ان الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت لها
تداعيه اقتصاديه كبيره للغايه سواء فيما
يتعلق بازمه الطاقه او ازمه الغذاء او
النقطه الاخرى التي كانت تشير اليها فاطمه
ايضا وهي خطوره الركود الاقتصادي لذا
فانتم تتشابك معا في نفس المحور هو في
النهايه كيف حال اهل الاقتصاد اساله واهل
السياسه
تحليل سياسي اقتصادي بحث لا اكتمال الصوره
لك ولمشاهدي العربيه
نحن الان كما هو معروف في شرم نوفمبر
مقبلين على شهر ديسمبر مع نهايه العام 20
22 هذا العام الذي ربما لم يتعافى العالم
هناك تحضيرات بان هذه القمه قد تشكل
الفرصه الاخيره في هذا العام للانتقال الى
عام 20 23 بموقف دولي موحد فيما يتعلق
بهزامات المنطقه لذلك هناك تحضيرات بان
العام 20 23 سيكون عاما مختلفا اذا لم
تتخذ الجهود الان خاصه في قمه العشرين
موقف الدولي حازم فيما يتعلق بكل الخلافات
سلاسل الانداد ازمه الغذاء همم امتدادات
الطاقه ولكن يبقى الملف الاهم الخروج من
الازمات الراه هنا ما يتعلق مثلا
بالعلاقات ما بين واشنطن وبكل
ايجاد حل سريع
للازمه في اوكرانيا
صعب يجب ان ناخذ هذه المواضيع بجديه اكبر
اللي كي نجدها حل على الاقل خلال السنه
القادمه
مواضيع ساخنه رشا يتم الحديث عنها سواء
عبر الشماعات ثنائيه خارج اجتماع القمه او
خلال الاجتماع
العشرين بالاضافه لبعض الضيوف هناك ازمه
كبيره تؤرق الشرق الاوسط تحديدا ودول شمال
افريقيا كما تعلمين وهي ازمه الغذاء هل من
اخبار مطمئنه في كواليس هذه القمه لمحاوله
التفاعل وحل هذه الازمه
اذا وجدنا حل للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فنحن حنحل تقريبا 70 في المئه من هذه
المشكله رشا نحن نعلم ان اوكرانيا مصادر
الرئيسي للحبوب خصوصا للدول العربيه
الموجوده بالشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
سواء نتحدث عن مصر عن المغرب عن لبنان
وغيرها من الدول وبالتالي
معظم
التصدير ياتي من هناك الاراضي اللي كانت
من خلالها اوكرانيا تزرع الحبوب وتصدرها
للكثير من الدول تمتد منها بالكامل من قبل
الجهاز العسكريه الروسيه وعلى هذا الموضوع
كنا نتحدثنا في نشرات السابقه انه سالك
وهي منظمه تستثمر في الامن الغذائي تابعه
للحكومه السعوديه تابعه لصندوق
الاستثمارات السعودي مستثمر رئيسي في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لتحت استراتيجيه الامن الغذائي وخصوصا
الحبوب ومنتجات او المنتجات الرئيسيه
كدوره والحبوب لاعب ايسي وهذا اللي يتحدث
عنه الرئيس همم الاندلسي بشكل كبير نعم عن
الامن الغذائي الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيجاتيرش الذي يركز بشكل كبير على
ضروره حل
ازمه تصديرا حبوب من اوكرانيا وضروره
العوده مره اخرى الى الاتفاق اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب فتبقى من مزارع ومنقول في اوكرانيا
لابد من اعاده تصدير الحبوب من هذه ضمان
الامن الغذائي يبدو بان الامم المتحده
تدرك تماما بان التاخر في العوده مره اخرى
بفعاليه الى هذا الاتفاق ستسبب بشكل كبير
في ازمه غذاء عالميه وهذا ما جعل شي يركز
على هذا الملف في المؤتمر الصحفي
الاسيويه المنتجه
كافيه لا فتره غير واضحه الى متى يمكن ان
تستمر وه طالب ايضا انه ما يكون هذا
البوتكس يعني يكون فيه اغلاق
وتراجع التصدير وذلك هذا بيزيد يعرق
المشكله الامدادات والسلاسل الامداد بشكل
كبير احمد هذه الملفات الرئيسيه بالازمه
التي حدثت في همم ازمه كورونا رشا عندما
قررت بعض الدول الاحتقاد باللقاح لنفسها
وعدم تصديره الى الخارج الان نفس الازمه
تتكرر مره اخرى ولكن هذه المره في
المنتجات الزراعيه خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالحبوب الحب
ولا يمكن ان يكون العالم بمعزل عن هذا
الامر
بشكل واضح الاهميه الكبيره لقمه العشرين
هذه المره في ضوء الازمات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه نحن سنبقى معكم على راس
الساعه ايضا في هذه التغطيه الحيه
والمباشره من مدينه بالي الاندونيسيه حيث
انعقاد قمه العشرين وربما يعني كان هناك
بعض النفس ما بين العاصمه جاكرتا وما بين
بالي باعتبار ان جاكرتا هي عاصمه
اندونيسيا ولكن القمه تقام في بالي شكرا
لكم
الصحفيه خلدون الازهري مرحبا بك سيد خلدون
وبما تابعت معنا العرض الذي قدمه موفد
العربيه وهي موضوعات مهمه للغايه نبدا
بالازمات الملحه للغايه وهي التدعيه
الاقتصاديه لهذه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فيما يتعلق بازمتي الغذاء والطاقه هل يمكن
ان نجد مخرجا حقيقيا يتفق عليه قاده ال 20
لحل هذه الازمه وانقاذ دول العالم
المختلفه
نعم ربما ان روسيا مهدت لذلك قبل انعقاد
القمه عندما قررت تخفيف الحصار على
الموانئ الى الاوكرانيه لتصدير الاغذيه
وهذا سهم في خلق بيان ايجابي في اثاره
اجواء ايجابيه وفي
امل بتخفيف هذه الازمه الغذائيه العالميه
لكن هذا حل بسيط جدا ما زالت هذه القمه
سوف تركز على المشاكل الاكثر وهي مشاكل
معروفه الاكثر خطوره مثلا مشكله الديون
العالميه اكثر من 54 دوله تعاني من هذه
الديون منها الارجنتين همم في اسيا هل
تنجح هذه القمه بذلك همم
شعرنا بانها الرئيس الاندونيسيه تحدث
وكانه زعيم لحركه عدم الانحياز التي لا
تريد العالم والدول من خلاف المتعلق
باوكرانيا وهذا موقف يشهد له هو في الواقع
هو ارسل بيانا تحذي لقاده قمه بان عليهم
ايجاد حلول وليس تحويل هذه القمه الى قمه
لوي الازرق للتحالف مع الذين يعرضون روسيا
او الذين يعيدونها روسيا في الواقع لم
تبدو بانها تحاول لو الازرق احد واا الصين
تحاول ايضا تريد تعزيز العلاقات مع
الولايات
في ظل استمرار هذه الحرب وهي مساله الركود
الاقتصادي هذا يهدد العالم باكمله
وبالتالي هذا الملف يتصدر ايضا اجنده هذه
القمه
بالتاكيد عقود الاقتصادي له عده اسباب
وليس فقط الحرب في اوكرانيا وايضا هناك
الدول الغربيه نفسها تعاني من التضخم
وارتفاع الاسعار ولهذا تحاول الخروج من
هذه الازمات هذه القمه طبعا لن تحل
المشكله في تلك الدول ولكن التعاون بين
الجميع سوف يساعدهم على تجاوز ازمات
اضافيه وتكبير المشاكل التي يعاني منها
العالم لناخذ مثال على همم قطاع الطاقه
هذا اليوم وافقت همم روسيا او امس هو فقد
روسيا على بقاء اليابان في مشاريع سخنين
واحد في الشرق الاقصى الروسي هذا مشروع
هام للطاقه تهتم به اليابان بشكل كبير مع
مشروع سخنين اثنين الذي ايضا همم توجد
بحصص يابانيه كبيره هذا التعاون النفطي
بين اليابان وروسيا يؤكد انه ان الخلاف
السياسي بين البلدين لن يؤثر ولا كان يؤثر
على التعاون في مجالات غير ذلك لهذا ال-
ال- يجب على قاده القمه حسب ما يقول هنا
بعض المسؤولين همم اليابانيين ان يحاولوا
العدم توريد القمه بهذه المشاكل السياسيه
التي ليس لها سوى حل سياسي وليس لها حل
اقتصادي
سيد خلدون فرضت نفسها وبقوه على الاجنده
الاقتصاديه لان التداعيات الاقتصاديه لهذه
الحرب وخاصه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه هي
التي ادت الى هذا الوقت ازمه غذاء همم
ازمه طاقه همم مؤشرات لركود اقتصادي هناك
مؤشرات معينه هي التي قادت الى هذا المشهد
نعم يجب ان نعترف بان معظم الازمات
الاقتصاديه في العالم كان السبب سببها
المحرك وانتشار فيروس كورونا وليس الحرب
الاوكرانيه تحديدا لهذا يجب ان يعني يتسب
المشاركون بالحكمه نوعا ما وعدم محاوله
تراشق الاتهامات بشكل كبير
والخروج ببيان نهائي هناك خلاف كما تعرفون
همم
الجانب الغربي يريد ادراج اوكرانيا في
البيان ختامي بينما ترفض ذلك روسيا لهذا
همم توريد هذه القمه بمشاكل سياسيه همم
وصلت الى طريق مسدود لن يؤدي بها الى اي
حال في هذه الدول غير المنحازه الى احد
مثل الهند والمملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي
دوله في الدول في المجتمع الاسلاميه كما
يقول احد مسؤولي وزاره الخارجيه هنا لهم
دور كبير مع اندونيسيا في همم اداره دفه
هذه القمه نحو التعاون ونحو التخفيف حده
المواجهه بين المعسكر الغربي وربما
المعسكر الروسي اذن المسؤوليه اكبر من اي
وقت مضى على الدول التي لم تكن في ليست
اعضاء في مجلس الامن والدول التي تحاول ان
يكون لها صوت مسموع بشكل كبير في هذه
القيمه لانها تمثل العالم بمجمله وليس
مجرد المواجهه الحاليه السياسيه بين الغرب
وبين الروس اذن هذه القمه فرصه ايضا
تاريخيا للخروج ببيانات وبي- حلول ربما
تكون جزئيه وناقصه الى حد ما ولكن على
الاقل لن تكون فاشله كما حذر الرئيس قال
اندونيسي في كلمته الاختياحيه
شكرا لك
وانا قبل متابعه بعد الاخبار ردا على هجوم
الحلقه ثوريه الصاروخيه ضد مقررات كرديه
في كردستان العراق ومقتل شخصين دعى مركز
تعاون الاحزاب الكردستانيه الايرانيه
الشعب الايراني لدخول في اضراب عام يوم
الخميس المقبل كما طلبت مجموعه شباب احياء
طهران من المواطنين الايرانيين عدم دفع
فواتير المياه والكهرباء والغاز وعدم
القيام بعمليه المصرفيه واغلاق ما تجريهم
ايضا طلبت مجموعه شباب احياء ايران من
الناس مقاطعه الشركات التي تقوم بنشر
الاعلانات في التلفزيون من جاتها دعت
مجموعه شباب احياء تبريز ايضا في بيان الى
اقامه تجمعات الاحتجاجيه كبيره وطلبوا
باغلاق المدارس والجامعات والشركات
التجاريه اعتبارا من يوم غدا الاربعاء
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبيه فرض عقوبه اضافيه
على 29 فرضا وثلاثه كيانات في ايران على
خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات واوضح الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان العقوبات جميلات وزير
الداخليه الايراني والتلفزيون الرسمي
وكذلك قائد القوات البريه الايرانيه وقضت
في الحرس الثوري
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي رحب
بالعقبات الاوروبيه الجديده على ايران على
خلفيه قمع الاحتجاجات معتبرا ان انتهاكات
ايران لحقوق الانسان يجب الا تمضي دون
عواقب واعرب في بيان عن قلق الولايات
المتحده البالغ اذا الاعتقالات الجماعيه
والمحاكمات للمتظاهرين في ايران وشدد
صلبنا على ضروره وقف تعذيب وايسات معامله
المعتقلين السياسيين في ايران واكد البيت
الابيض انا واشنطن ستواصل مع الحلفاء
محاسبه المسؤولين عن قمع الاحتجاجات في
ايران
السنكره رئيس مجلس النواب الليبيه عقيل
صالح ما تعرض له اعضاء المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في العاصمه طرابلس ومحاصره مجموعات
المسلحه لهم مطالبا النائب العام في حادثه
تهديد وترهيب اعضاء مجلس الدوله بقوه
السلاح ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها وتقديمهم
للعداله
وكان رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله ليبيا
خالد المشري وصفا حكومه البيبه بالحكومه
الملكيه وانها تسعى للسيطره على البلاد
عبر فرد الراي بالقوه
احنا هنستانف جلستنا وبعون الله هنمشي في
اجراءاتنا القانونيه
وقفنا من هذه الحكومه هيكون واضح بانها
حكومه ميليسيويه تريد السيطره بالقوه وفرض
رايها بالقوه
لتسريح 10,000 موظف ابتداء من هذا الاسبوع
حيث سيكون هذا اكبر خفضا للموظفين في
تاريخ الشركه وسيؤثر هذا بالطبع بشكل
اساسي على تنظيم اجهزه امازون وقسم البيع
بالتجزئه والموارد البشريه كما ستمثل
عمليات التسريح المبلغ عنها اقل من واحد
بالمئه من القوى
العامله العالميه في امازون وثلاث في
المئه من موظفي الشركه
قبضت السلطات الامريكيه على المشابه به في
حادث اطلاق النار بجامعه فرجينيا
الامريكيه والذي اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
واصابه اثنين اخرين وذلك بعد ساعات من
اطلقه الرصاص على حافله مليئه بالطلاب
العائدين من جوله الميدانيه وادعت الشرطه
الطلاب والموظفين الى الاحتماء في اماكنهم
لساعات لتنفيذ عمليه مطارده ضبط هذا
المشتبه به
ختاما العالم
انطلاقه قمه مجموعه ال20 في بالي ورئيس
الاندونيسيه يدعو الى تجنب حرب عالميه
اخرى
الاحزاب الكردستانيه الايرانيه تدعو
لاضراب العام ردا على هجوم الحرس الثوري
على كردستان العراق
المجلس الاعلى للدوله عقده جلسته بترابلس
نلتقي بعد قليل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]